first of all nominations for best actor
in a leading role Colin Farrell Brendan
Fraser and Austin Butler
nominated alongside Bill Nye and Paul
eskal
meanwhile best actress in a leading role
Kate Blanchett earns a nomination
alongside Michelle yo Andrea risborough
scored a surprise nomination
Anna De armas and Michelle Williams also
receiving a nod in this category Best
Director another big one hoping to take
home that award Steven Spielberg for his
autobiographical film The Fable man
uh Duo Daniel Quan and Daniel shut
sheinart I hope I pronounced that
correctly I'm sure they will pronounce
it much better than me on the night have
also been nominated for their movie
everything everywhere all at once uh
also nominated Martin McDonough
toddfield and Reuben osland
uh entertainment correspondents Katie
Spencer and Claire Gregory are here with
me and we're nodding at my pronunciation
I got that that was all right so thank
you thank you award for pronunciation I
don't get many of those um right ladies
uh what exciting afternoon let's go into
best picture category first because that
got expanded not so long ago didn't it
to include 10 films there's a lot there
for the judges to choose from which
really does make it a much more
interesting race because rather than the
Oscars being sort of accused of being
films nominated that nobody's ever seen
it means now the films that everyone's
gone out to see are actually in the
running and In Contention so things like
Top Gun massive summer blockbuster took
Everyone by surprise by how good it is
look that's done so well today
um as has you've got names coming up
things like the Batman which you know
for the production and for for sound and
things like that
um Elvis as well very polarizing film
people either loved it or hated it
that's in contention contention of the
best picture Avatar as well again didn't
do too well critically but it has proven
to be hugely popular in the box office
taking over a billion pounds what a week
for Avatar it passes the two billion
Mark and gets the best picture nod they
must be absolutely delighted
um where should we go next should we go
actually because we were talking about
this off air before before weren't we
and the best actress category and uh the
surprise nomination was Andrea
risborough really interesting actress a
Brit uh likes her Independent films but
also will appear in big Blockbusters as
well she's such a chameleon why was this
um such a turn up for the books if you
like because generally to be in the
running for one of these Awards you have
to have a studio behind you that has
been pushing your film to to everyone
who needs to go out to holding parties
holding special screenings this film
didn't have that basically all of the
actresses within Hollywood have seemed
to have got together and really made a
concerted push for people to be talking
about Andrea rise for his performance in
this because it is just an incredible
form that she gives into Leslie playing
a someone that won the lottery and then
lost all her money and has struggled
with addiction since
um and yeah it seems to have done the
trip she's now on the list up against
Kate Blanchett who everyone thinks is
one of the Front Runners yeah somebody
pointed out on Twitter that Kate
Blanchett actually when she wins an
Oscar it's for when she plays the title
role which she does in this film so
that's a little bit of movie trivia that
I picked up earlier on and but Claire
just explained to us a bit about how the
campaigning for the Oscars works because
that's the interesting element to the
Andrea risborough story isn't it because
normally you need big budgets that's
right you need to really woo these
judges normally these campaigns have
started months and months and months ago
they tend to kick off at festivals like
the Toronto International Film Festival
things like that and it's almost kind of
pre-planned pre-ordained at those times
we almost sort of know who we'll be
talking about come this time of year and
yeah Andrea risborough's campaign if you
like started one week before voting on
the Oscar nominations closed so I mean
what an incredible campaign they will be
teaching this in film school for years
well that's going to be one to watch on
the night can we talk about other Brits
as well particularly in the best actor
and best uh supporting actor category
it's been an incredible uh announcement
really for Irish talent as well the
Banshees of inner sharing because it is
an Irish British co-production but full
of Irish acting talent in there
um they've got four acting nominations
haven't they Colin Farrell for best
actor Kerry Condon and a supporting
actress and then you've got Brenda
Gleason up against Barry Keegan in the
supporting actor so same film yeah
always good fun and then of course Paul
maskell who's also Irish kind of
probably quite surprised some people
getting a best actor nod to a burst on
the scene in the last couple of years
hasn't he and now he has very Oscar
nomination under his belt but also I
mean in within the best stats category
as well going up against Brendan Fraser
will they favor more of an American
Canadian actor his tale is like a
Hollywood comeback Tale in itself isn't
it and talk about the campaign the uh
chat about awards has been going on for
a while with him and in fact when I
caught up with him to talk about the
film The Whale he was aware that there
was plenty of Buzz around his
performance
the award stuff
it's new to me but we're all frothy and
happy and Giddy and happy for this with
fingers crossed and best fondest hopes
for success but who knows what the
result is going to be but I'm confident
I think that we've got a shot at making
it to the finish line
thank you
and just the other thing to note as well
when we were talking about the baftas
last week we're all a little bit sad
that the fave woman's only got one
nomination it's done so much better it's
up for for best pictures Spielberg's up
for best director it's a take on his
childhood and his parents separating
definitely done a lot more well here at
the Academy Awards and rightfully so
really